Jay if you do 200 Impressions to me that
seems like a slam dunk home run for
Saturday Night Live In other words
they're always looking for characters
but my first year when I was I was
walking down the hall I'd just be doing
random characters I gotta edit got Eddie
Murphy impression anybody needed Eddie
Murphy president I got one what's your
Eddie Murphy can I can I ask you for a
couple of those because I love it did
Eddie Murphy now he's just real you know
he's cool and he's just like this and
you know I have a lot of kids you know I
like to I like to sleep with with a lot
of I like to sleep with box and have
babies that's what I like to do he's not
like he's not like this you know what I
mean to be turning up and be doing all
that with your fingers and the voices
this is like Eddie Murphy this is Eddie
Murphy when Eddie Murphy doing the
character Howard let me ask you a
question if you had all the
responsibility of the country you think
your hair would still be black it
wouldn't I went from jet black to Cisco
in four years
what was the best part of living in the
White House uh I think it was uh going
downstairs and in the morning uh with
Michelle and you know blocking out all
the security cameras and I have an
intercourse on George Washington's face
that's what we did
WOW Pete do you have a nickname for your
schlong I would imagine that uh there's
some you named it I call it Sauron from
Lord of the Rings yeah really Sauron
yeah because it you know it's you know
like Sauron was unlike that that that
Tower and the tower was like higher than
everything and right it's the eye was up
there and he always like focused on like
the right thing all of a sudden you
start looking like Denzel you talk like
Denzel you look like him and you start
thinking like Denzel Howard that's what
it's about right huh see that all these
movies I've done for years and I've
never done a sequel except for the
equalizer so if they keep making them
and it keeps making money
I'll keep doing it you understand Howard
Howard look it's like this you know I
know like I'm 200 I'm 200 pounds I'm six
foot two Chris Rock is five foot ten 45
pounds like it should have run ever
never happened keep Chris Rock's name
team out your [__] mouth okay it was
like yeah we were just we were just
sitting around and you know then all of
a sudden they just started to they
started filming again they started
filming and hey we've got a shark how
would man you know what's crazy man
these young [__] man they don't
know [__] Generation Z doesn't even know
how to write cursive [__] that's crazy
man you think dinosaurs existed yes how
do you know you ain't never seen one
well I mean I I've never seen one do you
believe the Earth is flat what are you
thinking chickens can fly how would
chickens can fly
you know why chickens stop Flying so we
could get to we could get close to them
they used to be able to fly they were
flying before you're such a loyal fan of
the Knicks you you love going and I see
you sit right up front and you start
yelling at the Players
that's what I do pop up
yeah but don't they get angry with you I
mean no they don't get angry at me
Howard I'm Tracy Morgan why would they
get angry at me but you can't coach the
Knicks I mean you're yelling at the
Players they're going up and down the
court and you're yelling at them I mean
you can't if I don't coach them who will
Howard
foreign